[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler d'une
passion passion d'une vie et je vous
dirai pourquoi c'est une passion d'une
vie la passion c'est l'afrique
avez vous conscience que ce continent
représente aujourd'hui un humain sur
cette qu'en 2050
il représentera un humain sur quatre en
2100 il représentera un humain sur trois
combien d'entre vous perçoivent le
continent africain en se disant voilà un
continent plus grand que les états unis
plus grand que la chine plus grands
comme l'un des plus grands que la russie
plus grand que le japon plus grand que
la france
plus grand que d'italie plus grands
clubs d'espagne plus grand que le réunis
voilà quelque chose qui fait réfléchir
je m'appelle ababacar dingue je suis né
au sénégal et j'ai été formé au prytanée
militaire de saint-louis où j'ai obtenu
mon baccalauréat
le prytanée militaire de saint-louis en
lice et panafricain qui reçoit des
sénégalais bien sûr mais des ivoiriens
des béninois des burkinabè des nigériens
des tchadiens des centrafricains les
gabonais en lycée où on nous enseigne
on nous apprend le courage l'endurance
le respect de l'autre la solidarité
l'amitié
mais surtout on nous enseigne la
discipline et la quête de l'excellence
je passe cette année dans ce lycée
militaire
on a deux bises et savoir pour mieux
servir servir puisque qu'une devise
c'est en fait une vertu cardinale
je passe cette année au prytanée
militaire de saint-louis et je sors de
là pétri de valeurs fortes et
d'enseignement scolaire qui me permette
effectivement d'aller en france pour
suivre des études de mathématiques
supérieures ce parcours universitaire ça
sert à quoi sert à quoi mon parcours
universitaire m'a toujours servi à
analyser les situations à réinventer des
côtes pour rendre des choses possibles
là où je suis souvent en relation avec
l'afrique qui est ma passion
j'arrive en 1997 à l'université de reims
champagne-ardenne
je suis le seul professeur de rang
magistral dans le département de gestion
il n'y a pas d'équipés de recherche en
gestion je me dis il faut monter une
équipe de recherche en question parce
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir d'université
de plein exercice sans recherche
je monte l'équipe de recherche en
gestion il ya en face de l'université de
reste qu'une école de commerce
extrêmement puissante
je savais que là où il y avait des
universités généralistes en face de
l'école de commerce
il fallait un nid à eux il fallait des
formations professionnalisantes jeudi
l'université doit site former des
personnes qui soient des personnes
employables il faut donc mettre en place
des mastères professionnels jeu gré le
master administration des entreprises
qui à l'époque s'appelait x1 d'ercis
certificat d'aptitude à d'administration
des entreprises
je participe à la création de deux
mastères professionnels deux autres
matières professionnelles gestion
stratégique des ressources humaines et
de la qualité est bonne gouvernance et
état de droit
c'était en 97 en 2011
suis ici même à abidjan pour présider
les jurys du concours d'agrégation du
commerce en sciences de gestion je
discute avec les candidats je fais une
réunion de préparation je leur explique
ma philosophie c'est la pédagogie de la
réussite
je veux que tous ceux qui le méritent
les médias nous donnerait à personne
qu'une de mérite et je leur demande
comment il se prépare comme il faut et
je me rends compte qu'ils sont très mal
préparée je leur demande quelles sont de
relations entre eux et avec des
entreprises et je constate avec
effarement qu'il n'y a pratiquement
aucune relation
et c'est ici à abidjan en 2011 que
l'intuition que la conviction de fonder
la société africaine de management 11g
rue
il faut mettre en place un dispositif
qui permette aux chercheurs en
management de se parler et qui doit
permettre de faire de travail vis-à-vis
de la société
lorsque j'avais l'intuition très forte
que le problème de l'afrique ce n'est
pas le sous développement
le problème de l'afrique c'est son saoul
management le sous développement n'est
que qu'une conséquence dans son
management en 2012 une première
rencontre a lieu à saint louis du
sénégal et à partir de 2013 les
conférences africaines de management
sont instaurés 2013 nous sommes à dakar
2014 nous sommes à cotonou 2015 sont à
douala 2016 nous sommes à ouagadougou
2017 nous serons à libreville et 2018
nous serons ici même à abidjan
si je n'ai pas le projet de décéder mais
nous savons je reviendrai là dessus que
nous avons d existence éphémère et nous
profitons du bonheur de la chance que
nous avons d'exister pour faire des
choses décoder réinventer et faire que
les choses soient possibles
donc voilà un certain nombre de choses
donc nous sommes en 2011 et à partir de
2011 des conférences africaines de
management en 2014
donc je vais faire l'aller retour entre
la france et l'afrique en 2014 je crée à
reims un master management en afrique
accueillis par le centre international
de recherche et de formation appliquée
au management
ce master management en afrique est le
premier et unique master à ma
connaissance en france
traitant spécifiquement de la
problématique encore du management en
contexte africain
la même année le 1er mars 2014
j'organise à paris à une veste et paris
dauphine la rencontre internationale de
lagaf' pourra de l'espace km est en
convaincu que la diaspora africaine a un
rôle extrêmement est en partie de la
diaspora universitaire un rôle
extrêmement important à jouer pour dans
l'émancipation de l'afrique en 2015 en
décembre 2015 la société africaine de
management signent un accord de
coopération de collaboration avec le
conseil africain et malgache pour
l'enseignement supérieur s'est doté d'un
plan stratégique de développement donc
la somme est un partenaire technique du
commerce en 2016
l'asam organise un programme de mobilité
des enseignants et des chercheurs
africains dans les meilleures
institutions du monde
donc qu'est-ce que ça signifie tout cela
ça signifie que pour un africain
il est possible de faire des choses en
afrique et partout dans le monde et ça
c'est évident pour ceux qui savent voir
ce que les autres ne voient pas
au-delà de cet aspect je voudrais vous
ça c'est des penchants professeurs on
pardonnera je vais essayer de ne pas
faire un cours magistral mais je vais
vous expliquer une prémonition
et comment chacun d'entre vous peuvent
être partie prenante intégrale active de
cette promotion la prémonition rester
assis et attaché des ceintures la
prémonition
c'est celle du leadership mondial de
l'afrique
nous travaillons à la société africaine
de management à la théorisation et la
concrétisation du leadership mondial de
l'afrique
ou est-ce qu'il faut rassurer les uns et
les autres oui peut-être
quand nous disons leadership mondial de
l'afrique ce n'est pas une affaire de
domination du monde et c'est ce qu'ils
sont des spécialistes de nietzsche
volonté de puissance
si on vous demande de résumer ce que
c'est que la révolution sam que nous
prenons et que nous concrétisons asseyez
vous ai expliqué clairement que la
révolution semble c'est la substitution
de la puissance de volonté à la volonté
de puissance
la puissance de volonté qui nous anime
et qui est le leadership que nous
voulons pour l'afrique c'est une
puissance de volonté de bien vivre
ensemble
nous voulons construire en afrique et
dans le reste du monde un cadre d' envie
de bien vivre ensemble un cadre de paix
un cadre d'ouverture au reste du monde
un cadre de prospérité partagent un
cadre de tolérance donc c'est ça
l'objectif
alors que quand vous voyez dans le reste
du monde des régions qui ont été des
coeurs de l'humanisme
ces régions commencent a repoussé autrui
nous voulons ici en afrique ce que nous
appelons le leadership mondial de
l'afrique ce n'est pas la volonté de
puissance économique
la volonté de puissance militaire la
volonté de puissance culturelle
ce que nous voulons c'est la puce
volonté de vivre ensemble d'accueillir
les gens mais alors entation de faire en
sorte que nos potentiels qu'il ya dans
chacun d'entre nous soit un potentiel
qui s'exprime à fond ne voulons pas que
les gens connaître les deux erreurs
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure des
erreurs qui fasse que il ne voit pas des
potentialités et des erreurs qui fasse
que il croit à des fictions et cette
affaire de leadership mondial de
l'humanité
l'énergie mondiale de l'afrique j'ai
coutume de dire regardez mandela
regardez l'afrique du sud
voilà des gens c'est un exemple concret
voilà des gens qui ont concrétisé et mis
en place la réconciliation du bourreau
et de la victime ou es ce que vous avez
vu ailleurs dans le monde
une concrétisation de cette
réconciliation du bruit et d'habiter
ailleurs les gens partent de réparation
vous réparez vous payez vous et c'est
donc le type de deux heures sup dont
nous parlons c'est de mettre la barre
très haut en termes de pays en termes
d'ouverture à autrui en termes de
prospérité partagée en termes de
tolérance
j'ajouterai en termes de développement
durable ailleurs ailleurs qu'en afrique
at on vu des exemples de d'écologie
industrielle de recyclage des terrains
de respect de l'environnement
le leadership mondial de l'afrique c'est
cette affaire là alors en prenant appui
sur l'ambition en prenant appui sur la
détermination en prenant appui sur la m
chacun d'entre vous est capable de
réussir cette affaire est-ce que
l'ambition de leadership mondial de
l'afrique
quelques jeunes est définie est une
ambition qui est légitime je vous ai dit
on compte n'a plus vaste que les états
unis que la chine que l'art est que la
russie que le japon que la plupart des
pays de l'europe de l'ouest réunis
continent qui fait un cinquième de
l'humanité va faire un quart à un tiers
de l'humanité dès 2050 le potentiel des
ressources humaines de plus importants
dans le monde
sera pas en chine se fera pas en inde ce
sera en afrique il faut être capable de
voir ce que les autres ne voient pas il
faut être capable de voir ce que les
autres ne voient pas il faut avoir une
ambition sans limites
une détermination sans faille et puis il
faut travailler avec méthode réinventer
des comptes
on peut le faire de plusieurs manières
la première c'est de prendre décote
existant alors il faut pas réinventer
les codes pour les réinventer il faut
réinventer les codes pour bien faire
pour faire bien pour faire le bien
on peut prendre des côtes tel quel ça
vaut savoir pour mieux servir
c'est un de mes codes sur le prytanée
militaire de saint-louis apprendre à
oser c'est un de mes codes c'est l'école
hec à paris on va chercher les coups de
partout mais on peut dire aussi
why should white guys have all the fun
why should have fun c'est le titre d'un
ouvrage de reginald rhuys réginald avis
un jeune africain américain de six ans
en tant ses grands-parents se plaindre
des discriminations à l'embauché à
l'encontre des africains américains
du haut de ses 6 ans sa première
réaction sa première question a été de
dire white shaun white 15 enfin et bien
ce petit garçon de 6 ans plein
d'assurance a été le premier africain
américain à mettre sur pied une
entreprise de plus d'un milliard de
dollars à sa mort prématurée à 50 ans en
1993 sa fortune personnelle est estimée
à plus de 400 millions de dollars
nous sommes tous ici reginald lévis en
puissance
l'afrique
les africains ont été dans leur dans
leur histoire récente opprimés et d'une
manière générale cette oppression fait
en sorte qu' ils manquent de confiance
en eux mêmes cela les a poussés jusqu'à
ignorer le leadership au plan mondial
qu'ils ont pu occuper à une certaine
époque de l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est pourquoi alors que nous sommes
dans un monde du savoir où les
ressources sont pas les ressources
naturelles des ressources les vraies
ressources
ce sont les compétences des savoirs des
connaissances dans ce contexte dans les
africains ont besoin d'un réarmement
cognitif mental qui leur permettent de
faire ressortir tout le potentiel qu'il
y à un noeud pour le leadership mondial
dont on a parlé et qu'on a bien défini
comme étant créer un espace dans vie de
bien vivre ensemble en espace de paix un
espace d'ouverture à autrui un espace de
prospérité partagée un espace dans
l'errance
en 2017 nous serons à libreville pour la
prochaine conférence africaine de
management
ce sera l'occasion de développer des
relations avec les entreprises avec les
institutions d'enseignement supérieur
pour faire en sorte que et avec les
collectivités territoriales avec les
décideurs publics pour faire en sorte
que le travail d'assistance technique le
travail d'appui technique qui est fait
par la sam avec le cas mais ce soit
étendu aux autres acteurs en afrique en
2018 je l'avais dis nous serons ici à
abidjan
mais nous serons ici à abidjan où nous
déploierons assez rapidement
l'université du leadership mondial de
l'afrique
abidjan est une priorité pour la société
africaine de management nous reviendrons
ici pour faire en sorte que les
dirigeants soient appuyés pour la
reconquête de l'afrique pour la conquête
du monde
nous ferons en sorte que des étudiants
ivoiriens soient formés ivoiriens et
africains soient formés aux métiers de
l'avenir et nous ferons en sorte que ces
étudiants là soient préparés accompagner
pour que nous ayons les futures
générations les futurs prix nobel
africain de physique de chimie de
médecine de biologie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]